[Music]
who's the girl she's a princess Oh
aren't they all know we've had a
connection but she has to marry a prince
back up boy I need some room to work I
made you to look like a prince on the
outside but I didn't change anything on
the inside Prince I ve got you to the
door
do you trust me what did you say but
Aladdin has to open it do you trust me
[Music]
sometimes princess you just have to take
a risk
[Music]
[Music]
you stumbled upon an opportunity
I can make you rich rich enough to
impress a princess
what would I have to do there's a Cave
of Wonders
bring me the man
[Music]
oh great ones and summons me I stand by
my oath loyalty two wishes three I'm
kidding rush
[Music]
hey can you make me a prince there is a
lot of gray area in make me a prince I
could just make you a prince oh no you
look like a prince on the outside but I
didn't change anything on the inside
Showtime no I'm in charge okay I say
when it's done really
I thought a princess could go anywhere
not this princess do you trust me
[Music]
you
you